على كل حال سالنا الناس في السعوديه ما
الاصح برايك ان تاكل متى تشاء او ما تشاء
نتابع الاجابات
[موسيقى]
صراحه اكل متى احس اني احتجت للاكل
وبحكم اني انسانه رياضيه فبعد الرياضه هو
اكثر وقت انه الانسان يحتاج ياكل الاكل
يكون فل بروتين والله يعتمد صراحه قبل كنت
تاكل متى ما بغيت ومتى ما تشاء على قولتك
بس الحين دامنا في عيال صرنا مرات نرتبط
بالدوام يلزمك
رده العيال من المدارس مرات فحتى لو كنت
جوعان ما راح تقدر تاكل وخصوصا ان عيالك
بيجون بعد شوي بتاكل وياهم
متى ما رجعت من الدوام على حسب النوم متى
ما جعت اقدر اكل اللي وقعت معينه بالاكل
استغرب من بعض الناس مثل ما جاءك لا غلط
في وقت الفطور وفي وقت للغداء في وقت
العشاء والحمد لله طبعا في مقوله تقول
افطر فطور ملوك وتغدغد وتعشى فقراء
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات